für all diejenigen die der spd nicht
ohnehin tod und teufel an den hals
wünschen ist es ein gutes signal
olaf scholz hat seine bereitschaft
erklärt den vorsitz der spd zu
kandidieren scholz ist vizekanzler vor
allen dingen aber ist der
bundesfinanzminister
ein einflussreiches amt er ist sehr eng
in der zusammenarbeit mit
bundeskanzlerin angela merkel die beiden
haben ein gutes verhältnis scholz hat
etwas zu sagen im land und in der partei
er ist erste liga unter den
sozialdemokraten und der erste dieser
art der sich bisher in das
kandidatenrennen um den freien
spd-vorsitz eingeschaltet hat scholz
allerdings hat in der spd seit jeher ein
problem ist nicht besonders beliebt wann
immer er sich um ein amt beworben hat
waren seine ergebnisse mäßig oder aber
auch wirklich katastrophal schlecht und
vergessen die zeiten als er als
scholzomat verspottet wurde wegen seiner
etwas trockenen und spröden art
aufzutreten
aber das ganze ist nicht so schlimm denn
wichtiger noch als die frage ob olaf
scholz am ende spd vorsitzender sein
wird ist das signal dass endlich einer
aus dieser ersten liga der partei nicht
länger zu geguckt hat wie immer mehr
bewerber antreten sondern selber
gehandelt hat inzwischen sitzen auf den
bewerber karussell ja so viele menschen
dass man kaum noch durchblickt wer es
eigentlich im einzelnen ist und von
außen nicht so genau weiß soll man
lachen oder weinen über dieses theater
allerdings gibt es ein problem auch für
scholz vorsitzender einer großen partei
inhaber eines politischen führungsamt
ist wird man in der regel wenn man das
will wenn man das richtig anstrebt das
hat scholz bisher nicht getan
er hat sich nach langem langem warten er
die bereitschaft ist zu tun heraus
kitzeln lassen die frage ob dieses gute
voraussetzungen sind um ein starker
spd-vorsitzender zu werden ist
unbeantwortet
die spd ist vielleicht einen kleinen
schritt weiter gekommen heute aber aus
ihrem führungsschwach bisher noch nicht
heraus